[Music]
first days of school a heart I get it
I've been there but my first step middle
school with different I was sitting at
my desk feeling like an outsider at a
new school when I heard someone rush
towards me hey he said we're missing one
for Table Tennis in Chinese it's ping
pong so you in I hooked up being
surprised I I don't know how to play
ping pong it's okay he said we'll teach
you so he dragged me to a game was he
and his friends boys and girls and we
had a really good time now full
disclosure I still suck I have been fun
but I remember the feeling of warmth a
feeling included welcomed into that new
community the game brought me in four
years ago another friend of mine dragged
me to another game with him it was at an
old sports stadium three hours away from
Shanghai and it was boring ring that day
come on I said to him nobody is gonna
travel three hours in this horror line
green to watch people play video games
plus it's gonna be awkward I'm
definitely gonna be the only girl there
well three hours later I was sitting at
the stadium soaking wet and surprised to
find myself surrounded by over 10,000
fans they were young they were excited
the faces were painted in teen colors
and I looked out to the crowd I was
definitely not the only girl there in
fact almost half of the audience was
female when the game started it was like
someone lit a fire in the stadium a
dragon threw across the stream and the
crowd broke into roaring waves of chair
I looked around at the people hiding
around me somewhere older most were
younger
some were men some we're women and I
felt well
the king the video game is bringing
people together and that excited me for
the following three years I co-founded a
eSports company in China aiming to
create experiences just like this to
connect people through eSports and
gaming now fast-forward a couple years
last summer I moved to the US not had
heard about the difference between the
eastern game culture and the Western
game culture namely here it's a little
bit more boy centric so I wanted to
check it out myself I drove up north to
Oakland eSports arena to a game of
fortnight for at night is the massively
popular game here and it's one of the
most gender balance game here
it has over 46 percent of its player
base female I wanted to find a few
female gamers and ask them about about
their experience when I got there well
this is not a 10,000 people arena and
there were no dragons or anything but it
was still very cool it was a cool hip
arena with state-of-art computers when I
walked in the players and the fans were
glued to the screen immersed in their
game and behind them was this big screen
showing what was going on they didn't
notice me when I wanted but I noticed
something I was the only female there
and this is not a standalone incident
I've heard women on podcast in articles
talking about experiences similar to
mine finding themselves to be one of the
very few females at eSports events but
wait a minute if the stats are correct
the percentage of female gamers here in
the u.s. is actually quite comparable to
that in China in both countries almost
half of the gamer base or female and
where are the u.s. female gamers maybe
they just don't like offline events but
then I realize it's not just offline the
female gamers here are not showing up to
offline events and they're invisible
online to
my friend Claire tells me about her
experience
Claire is an excellent overwatch player
she's being playing the game since it
launched and she tells me that when she
plays overwatch she Mews her mic
why do you meet your mic I asked Claire
well she said cuz I don't want him to
find out I'm a woman what would happen
if they find out you're a woman what
would they do to you for one thing she
said they would not invite me to the
next game on the other hand there is
also that awkward private messages hey
how are you what are you doing what are
you wearing
come on I don't want any of that I just
I just want to play my game there is an
underlying assumption here about the
motivation of a female gamer namely if
you can't prove your authenticity if you
can't prove your gaming skills and your
love of gaming by beating every single
person out there that challenges you to
a game then you don't really like gaming
you're just doing it to get guys
attention now this reminds me of an old
joke which says women go to colleges
just to get husbands just to get Mrs
degree now that joke is over a half a
century old but we're here in 2020 and
gaming is new it's no longer that small
niche industry in the 60s and 70s it's
now a giant industry overtaking the
entertainment form the global gaming
industry is a hundred and twenty billion
dollars it's bigger than the global
movie box office and the music industry
combined 2.5 billion people around the
world are gamers so it's now a big
community got a big voice and what kind
of messages are we saying with this
voice
then I realized there's also a second
layer of the issue a less noticeable one
in 2015 there was this incident called
gamergate in which online trolls
attacked female video game producers
with brave threats and death threats
demanding them to get out of the
industry Brianna Wu a female video game
producer right at the center of
gamergate reflected on her experience
recently in her op-ed on new york times
she said I wish I could tell you things
have gone better five years since the
gamergate but they have it
she said we built worlds of fantasy for
men by men for men by men
now the issue we're seeing here in video
games is not fresh we've seen it before
we've seen it in Hollywood we've seen it
in traditional sports we've seen it
right here in Silicon Valley but we have
a unique window of opportunity here the
gaming industry despite its rapid growth
is still growing it's still small it
will grow bigger it's growing to take a
even more dominant part of our social
life and not just our generation but
generations to come
we've got to do something here what can
we do well I see three things to be done
one if you are a gamer well if you're a
female gamer I'll mute your mic speak up
because you deserve to be hurt if you
are male gamer actually mute your mic
try this for a change will you go home
tonight sign on to your favorite game
and create a new ID a female ID with a
female name and see what happens to you
and notice how you feel what you would
like to be changed to if you were run a
game company which I know some of you
may go on to do think about who you are
bringing onto your creative staff think
about who you have on your production
team because the digital world just like
our real world should be created for
everyone by everyone isn't it
three if you are none of the above
well whatever your form of gameplay is
pokiman go Jenga
Texas Hold'em bring someone and invite
someone bring them in when I moved here
last summer I brought my two kids with
me a six year old and a two year old I
remember feeling very nervous taking
them to their first playdate
will he make friends will they be
accepted
coz when they moved here they didn't
speak a lick of English will they be
included or whether it be like their
mother when I was their age well they
just sit silently in the corner when we
got there the party had already started
the kids had laid out toys on the floor
blocks Lego a switch my kids jumped with
joy and immediately they rushed in and
the children started playing the games
brought them in thank you
[Applause]
[Music]